[Music]
this is sky news today live from levi on
the 20th day of the war in ukraine
more deadly russian strikes four people
are killed in a residential area of kiev
but the capital's mayor insists its
residents will stay and fight
everyone is angry i talk to the people
they don't want to leave
facing 15 years in jail the editor from
russian state tv who interrupted her
channel's broadcast
to protest against the war
more than three million refugees have
now left ukraine in the three weeks
since war began
despite the ongoing bloodshed positive
noises around peace talks with ukraine's
president zielinski hailing pretty good
progress
meanwhile the uk sanctions a further 350
russian individuals and entities
including the former president and prime
minister dmitry medvedev
speculation the sanctioned billionaire
roman abramovich is back in moscow after
his private jet lands in the russian
capital
and boris johnson angers human rights
and green campaigners ahead of a trip to
saudi arabia
[Music]
well hello good afternoon live from la
viv in the west of ukraine 20 days into
russia's invasion of this country
residential areas of the capital kiev
have again been damaged by heavy
overnight shelling the city's mayor
vitaly klitschko says four people were
killed we'll be hearing from him in a
few minutes time
the uk has also slapped sanctions on 350
further russian individuals and
institutions who together have a
combined worth of more than a hundred
billion pounds meanwhile ukraine's
president vladimir zelensky has said
that peace talks with russia will
continue today despite the bloodshed and
has appealed directly to russian troops
to surrender
well just a few blocks away from where
we are is the saint peter and paul
garrison church in the last few hours
the funerals for four ukrainian soldiers
have taken place there they were killed
in the russian attack on the yavariv air
base near the polish border on sunday
the soldiers have been named as colonel
olay sashishin born in nineteen sixty
six major sergi melnick born in 1983
major krillo vishin vanyi who was born
in 1986 and the youngest also a major
rusty slav ravanchuk born in 1991 making
him just
20 or 21 years old
well earlier i spoke to colonel anton
maranovich who told me what a difference
the international support is currently
making to ukraine
we feel very
high level of support from the
for international support we're getting
financial support
materials
we're getting like
even uh international legion that
consists from the foreigners from all
over the world it's very you know it
makes us stronger because we we can feel
that we are not alone in this very tough
situation for us and we are stronger
together anyways
uh so when if it uh
if it will continue to be like this you
know we will feel this if the level of
the
of the support and health will increase
i hope i think it will be stronger and
we will do what we are supposed to do we
will defeat this
russian invaders
let's take you through then the day's
developments here in ukraine the polish
czech and slovenian prime ministers are
traveling to kiev where they're expected
to present an aid package from the
european union
russian and ukrainian negotiators are
expected to continue a fourth round of
talks via video link which began
yesterday
on the ground the red cross says the
situation in the besieged city of
mariupol is extreme and people are
essentially being suffocated in the city
with no aid
and the international organization for
migration says more than three million
people have now fled ukraine
well let's show you what's been
happening then across the country
[Music]
as we've heard russian attacks on the
capital kiev are intensifying with these
residential areas of the city itself and
a metro station hit this morning another
attempt to send aid into the besieged
city of mariupol appears to have been
unsuccessful however the city council
says two thousand private cars have now
been able to escape the city about three
hundred residents managed to leave
yesterday well meanwhile russia says the
entire kershawn region is now under
their control forces are believed to be
preparing for an advance on odessa
ukraine's third city and crucial
economic hub
elsewhere the runway at dunipro's
airport was destroyed in an overnight
attack the region's governor has said
the city has until recently been seen as
a safe haven for people escaping the
fighting but was targeted for the first
time last week
and in the west the number of people
confirmed killed in a strike on a tv
tower in the rivner region yesterday has
risen to 19 according to local
authorities
skies ashish joshi reports now on the
day's main developments
[Music]
the bombardment began at dawn
this residential neighborhood just
outside kiev shaken by large explosions
the russian invasion is inching slowly
towards the capital
moscow says it only has strategic
targets in its sights
not here though
this is where ordinary ukrainian
families live
it's very difficult yesterday we
extinguished one fire today another
people are dying and the worst thing is
that children are dying they haven't
lived their lives and they have already
seen this this is the worst
the same devastation has been visited on
other kiev neighborhoods
daylight shows the true extent of the
destruction
caused by overnight russian strikes
around 10 past four i was still asleep
and then i heard this loud explosion so
i jumped out of my bed my first thought
was that everything was okay i'm still
alive my second thought was that my
parents were still asleep so i pushed
open my door because it was stuck i saw
that my family was alive we grabbed our
things and tried to go out through the
staircase but everything was in smoke so
we decided to stay in the apartment and
wait for the rescuers
the ukrainian president remains in the
country and remains defiant 20 days into
the russian invasion he continues to
implore european leaders to intervene
and stop the bloodshed joining a meeting
in london of nordic and baltic leaders
he warned the russian aggression would
not stop
at his borders
there has to be prohibition for the
russian navy to use the
naval ports of the world we have to
disconnect
the russian banks from swift completely
we have to
acknowledge russia as they're off state
and there has to be a trade embargo with
russia this is something that we need
and something you need as well
boris johnson accepts more can
and should be done to help ukraine
you talk about uh trying to protect
ukraine from the air vladimir who can
listen to your appeals uh without a
sense of urgency and uh who this is a
desperate desperate moment and i think
we must try to do more particularly uh
to support you in
protecting the ukrainian people from uh
from uh bombardment by uh by artillery
and and uh by aviation
but as these promises of support are
made the onslaught on the ground
continues
some 3 million ukrainians have been
forced to flee the russian bombardment
those who have not been able to leave
face an increasingly desperate
and dangerous future
joshi
well the mayor of kiev italy klitschko
has said that four people have been
killed in airstrikes on the ukrainian
capital this morning our special
correspondent alex crawford has spoken
to him
we see the result
of bombing
civilian
people
died
last morning
is we was one district a balloon
where people killed
today in other apartments building
we see we don't know exactly the numbers
uh of uh people we
have not entrance to every four
but right now close to 50 people
actually ever create a lot of a lot of
them injured
[Music]
we give the full support to everyone
how would you describe the spirit of the
ukrainian people and your feeling about
this
the spirit right now everyone is angry i
talk to the people they don't want to
live
in this activity
bring much more
energy to everyone and everyone
understand don't want to live want to
depend defend our city
talk to the people
they it's not disappointing
they really upset what
what russian soldiers do it we see them
but
everyone i talk to the people simple
people instead to make evacuation to the
to west of ukraine
they asked about their weapons and talk
we're ready to be in serial defense and
defend our houses
how can they defend themselves against
attacks like this which are very random
right now it's i call to everyone every
civilian
please spend the time it is possible in
bunkers
and what about the grounds for possible
war crimes and referring these sort of
attacks to the international criminal
court do you think there is a basis for
war crimes being committed here yes of
course it's it's it's international
criminal case what russians do it with
civilian people in our country
we have a lot of examples in other
cities puja airplane gastoni
almost destroyed
right now we see they
break exactly the same what happens in
harkin mariupol right now the same
scenario we see in our hometown and here
you have european leaders coming here
today to here to show their support but
is that enough what else should be
happening it's never enough
with all the unity of democratic war
world
around ukraine is very important because
we fighting not just our for our city
we're fighting right now not just for
our country we're fighting all together
for our our values our principles
natalie klitschko talking to alex
crawford there will hear the uk
government has announced 350 new
listings under its russia sanctions
regime which includes the former
president and prime minister dmitry
medvedev
the restrictions were announced as the
prime minister chaired a meeting of
nordic and baltic leaders in london
ahead of a controversial trip to saudi
arabia later today hello deputy
political editor sam coats is at
lancaster house in central london on the
sanctions first sam uh there's a lot
more names added here and a and with a a
huge combined net wealth this bunch of
uh oligarchs
that's right it is a significant moment
the british government have been
scrambling to change the rules in the
last few days in order to uh allow
essentially a sort of catch-up exercise
with the european union uh where we can
now uh sanction the same people that the
uh the eu have gone after um liz trust
will stand up in the commons later today
to outline uh the full details but in
addition to individuals there are also
luxury items that are being sanctioned
today
russian vodka one thing highlighted uh
by the government
in an attempt really to put the squeeze
further but one of the questions as
leaders from baltic and scandinavian
countries heard alongside boris johnson
president zelensky pose is what more can
they do and it's not clear just how much
there is left in the locker
uh for uh western countries when it
comes to putting pressure uh on
president putin
by using simply mechanisms like
sanctions
i think that what the world is seeing is
the
uh return in ukraine to the kind of
brutality the kind of
absolutely indiscriminate bombing of
civilian centers of uh
great cities that we last saw in the
european continent 80 years ago
this is quite unbelievable what is
happening now in in our continent
and we need to make sure that we build
the strongest widest possible
coalition
to ensure that vladimir putin does not
succeed that we wean ourselves off
russian hydrocarbons and that's what the
uk is is helping to do
so that was boris johnson making a
broader point as we head into a round of
global diplomacy that boris johnson is
going to embark on in the next few days
he'll be heading to saudi arabia later
today
to meet with the crown prince he there
is also clearly discussions underway in
iran
one of the consequences of that could be
the release of nazanin
radcliffe who's been in detention there
from 2016. the question that you just
heard uh from boris johnson was in the
uh
the answer you just heard from boris
johnson uh was an answer to the question
whether or not it's suddenly become
quite a good moment to be a repressive
regime given all of a sudden britain
looks like it needs things from saudi
arabia and iran both countries that in
the past we've sought to portray perhaps
uh more as a more distant diplomatic
ally rather than somebody that we're
hugging close
sam thanks very much
well let's get more now from the eu on
sanctions against russia and an eu
delegation visit to kiev uh skies laura
bundock is in brussels for us i
understand that peace talks have now
resumed
yep that's right they have they were
paused yesterday all hopes pinning on
these peace talks from the russian side
certainly a sense of optimism
definitely a note of caution and a
sprinkling of cynicism i think when it
comes to any outcome yet but there are
high-level virtual talks with uh both
sides taking place meanwhile
from the eu's perspective we have this
really significant moment we have
european leaders the prime ministers of
poland slovenia and the czech republic
on their way as i speak via train to
ukraine to the capital kiev where
they're due to meet president zielenski
and ukrainian prime minister as well
they crossed over at the polish border
at seven o'clock in the morning that's
uk time the journey is going to take
them hours and hours but they are there
to show their unequivocal support a
delegation from the european union a
very interesting quote from the polish
prime minister on his facebook page
saying at such breakthrough times for
the world it is our duty to be where
history is forged he said now the three
leaders will be there they will discuss
the the packages of support that the eu
is offering we've been hearing about
this fourth set of sanctions from
brussels now so this is increasing the
existing packages it's a ramping up of
previous measures and new things as well
including a ban on the exports of
russian steel at the import of russian
steel are bound on the export of luxury
goods expensive cars diamonds caviar
cigars you name it going into russia and
then also in more individuals targeted
more organizations the biggest name
certainly that of roman abramovich and
of course
as well as the economic um sanctions
there is this huge humanitarian package
of support the eu is offering this open
borders policy no need for a visa for
anyone fleeing ukraine and then on top
of that you have the military role as
well the eu providing military support
to the ukrainians
and their and their operations on the
ground there but it is a massive moment
there you have these three leaders
arriving in ukraine in the capital which
is under shelling so the security threat
is huge seeing for themselves the
situation on the ground it really is a
moment of great significance when it
comes to the ultimate show of solidarity
and support to ukraine at the moment
laura thanks very much
let's get more now from the eu on
sanctions against russia
the international organization for
migration says the number of people who
fled ukraine has now passed some three
million so let's get the very latest
then from lisa holland who joins us now
from warsaw and already lisa you've
talked about the pressure that the
authorities are there on trying to
accommodate some of the people
presumably as the numbers pour in it'll
only get worse
yeah hi anna i mean these figures just
confirming really what you can
completely see with your own eyes
certainly here in the polish capital um
i i think what's interesting that in
some respects compared to the figures
that were working on you know just a few
days ago they're kind of almost to me
even worse than you might imagine um for
example
the last kind of broad estimate was that
uh poland where the lion's share of the
refugees have come out of the bordering
neighbouring countries to ukraine the
figure that was generally being used was
that about a million and a half people
have passed into poland
now they're putting that figure at 1.8
million and i think that what's really
interesting in terms of the context of
these figures is that people here in the
polish capital were saying well look
okay if you get a million and a half
people now 1.8 million people passing
into poland actually how many are
passing through and how many does poland
have to deal with now a figure that's
come out uh today is that only about 300
000 of those 1.8 million have moved on
to other parts of europe we've seen a
lot of people trying to get buses and
trains trying to go off to germany
estonia latvia all over really so that
leaves you with a phenomenal number of
people who are staying here in poland
and the big thing to sort of take away
from all of this is that often when
we're covering um certain migration
crisis refugee crisis that you know i've
covered over recent years that people
are generally trying to kind of move
somewhere else they want to rebuild
their life somewhere else it's
completely different here people want to
almost like sit out the wall women and
children in a place of safety because
they have fundamentally
reasons to go home and that is that the
men have stayed to fight so they want to
go back to ukraine therefore they need
somewhere to stay in places like warsaw
and the surrounding areas um until
hopefully all of this is over and that's
putting an enormous amount of pressure
on the polish authorities also people
like the volunteers who are stepping up
say there is a kind of lack of
orchestration from central government um
they want that to change and they say
that frankly the eu and other countries
have just not donating enough money to
help people on the ground here
when all of this is over that is the
great unknown though isn't it lisa thank
you very much indeed
well russian state media say an internal
investigation is underway after an
anti-war protester interrupted a news
programme with a sign criticizing the
war in ukraine
marina obviously anikova held up a
poster saying stop the war don't believe
propaganda they are lying to you here
and she shouted stop the war no war
before the programme cut away
while the protester is an employee of
russia's channel one before carrying out
her protest she recorded this
[Music]
well in fact the french president has
just been speaking and has said that the
russian of the french embassy rather in
russia
will offer protection to journalists so
we will certainly hear more from mr
macro a little bit later meanwhile
russian prosecutors have asked for the
kremlin critic alexei navalny to be
moved to a maximum security prison
russian state media say they are also
seeking an additional 13 years in prison
for him on charges of fraud and contempt
of court recent sanctions imposed on
russian oligarchs are based on a list of
people compiled by mr navalny he's
already serving a two and a half year
sentence on charges which he says are
intended to silence him
well don't forget if you do scan the qr
code on your screen right now you can
listen to sky to sky news's daily
podcast where jonathan samuels is joined
by our data forensics journalist jack
taylor to analyze the latest footage
coming out of mario paul which has been
under attack for some 19 days you can
subscribe of course to the delhi
wherever you get your podcasts from
a reminder too that we will have a
special programme with the latest on the
conflict today
at 5 p.m 6 p.m and 10 p.m i'll be live
here and just a heads up as well coming
up at 9 this evening we'll have a
special edition of our business program
ian king live looking at the impact that
the war in ukraine is having on the
global economy
well life and live as you can see
continues here the ukrainian flags are
here the main square there's children
life goes on in the west but everybody's
very mindful after the funerals this
morning of those four senior officers
how serious the situation is elsewhere
in the country and after that attack
also uh in the west on sunday
but meanwhile boris johnson has
underscored
his commitment to his drive for energy
independence i'll be discussing that
with the former spokesman for the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe back in just a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy a
century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
well prime minister boris johnson today
has talked about energy independence
he's also talked about the need or the
mistakes that were made in crimea so let
me bring in somebody who was there at
the time from the organization for
security cooperation in europe michael
bossacute good to have you here so boris
johnson said we made a terrible mistake
back in 2014 not taking action would you
agree with him in retrospect oh
absolutely and it's also something the
ukrainians have said for a long time i
think a big mistake was also not putting
in a lot of fighting sanctions before
the russians invaded
because it was too late once they came
in and i think their
masters are debating that sort of thing
i think you're going to see even more of
a bromance with china for them to get
past some of these sanctions so
absolutely
so how would the world tolerate that
that's been the big question certainly
we heard from the u.s state department
last night not too happy about any
cooperation with china militarily they
said economically or just in general
support so what does the world do about
this
i don't think uh mr putin would have
done what he's doing now without the
commission if you will or the
impromature of china uh him and xi
jinping have you know kept tight
relationships all the way through covet
as well when no one was talking to each
other so i don't know how far the
chinese cooperation will go because
don't forget also they have very big
interests here in ukraine especially in
terms of agriculture precious memories
that sort of thing ukraine has a lot of
what they need so we may see a similar
scenario playing out as we did in
kazakhstan where china held russia back
to a certain extent but of course this
all remains to be seen what do we do
about gas and oil then obviously the
prime minister uh speaking about uh the
need to look elsewhere for energy saudi
arabia for example you know even iran
venezuela these aren't countries
necessarily that that are better so what
what does the world do well without due
respect to uh leaders from the united
kingdom they've been doing business with
dirty money for quite some time allowing
these oligarchs to come to the united
kingdom by these big properties with
laundered money but i think yeah that's
the only way out for the time being is
to go to some of these countries where
we don't necessarily have good relations
with and get gasoline from them and also
another step will need to be more so for
the united states is allow things like
fracking to happen we're going to have
to go back on some of those
environmental promises in order to uh
keep energy security yeah back to the
north sea is the point he's making as
well isn't it where do you see this
going now um
while you were here in crimea did you
ever see this as
as as as the end game you know crimea
first then the rest of ukraine was that
a prospect then
i think we felt that way um when i was
with the oec at that time uh we saw the
invasion of the illegal annexation of
crimea and also the we were there when
the little green men walked into the
nest and that back then there wasn't
much opposition pushing them back but
now of course the ukrainian armed forces
are much stronger
i'm afraid right now is that with mr
putin suffering great losses they're
running out of apparently certain
ammunition is that they're going to
resort to their old tactics that they've
used elsewhere lobbying grad missiles
shuttling populated centers into
submission and then the other thing that
we see happening right now of course is
the weaponization of migration we could
see up to a quarter of ukraine's
population 10 million people going
across borders those numbers are
trending that way at the moment uh so
europe and countries further away like
my own canada have to be prepared to
really open their hearts to migrants
from here that's interesting i mean
that's an enormous refugee crisis but
look around you here there's children
over there blowing bubbles uh there's uh
buskers in the square i mean some of
these people here might be refugees
who've settled here this was a country
that was normal apart from that russian
build-up and then the subsequent
invasion and the bombardment that we see
now
yeah it's almost a split screen reality
uh what we're seeing here at the moment
uh playing out in the oven what's
happening in the east and southern parts
of ukraine but i talk to a lot of people
here and let there be no mistake there's
a lot of anxiety here uh don't forget
this is the birthplace of ukrainian
nationalism this is where a lot of
dissidents who were locked up in the
gulag came from this is where a lot of
the ukrainian diaspora including in the
united kingdom traced their roots back
to so it's very very important in the
ukrainian psyche but perhaps even to mr
putin to strike i'm afraid to say well
one person who knows that too well is
the former president petra poroshenko
i'm going to speak to now michael thank
you very much indeed for your time so
let's bring in uh petra poroshenko then
yet again another bombardment in kiev
the city where you are suffering a
deeply um former president
first of all we have a very difficult
20 days the most difficult history of
our country maybe one of the most
of the world only this night 12 missiles
cruise missiles was attacking civilian
object in here
where we now it's happening just a few
hundred meters from here
and definitely this is the changes of
the russian russian tactics because if
before you wanna keep the cities
untouched and make a
attempt to move further in ukrainian
territory when ukrainian armed forces
which we together created in a starting
from the year 2014
and i'm proud that uh for the last eight
years including my presidency we create
one of the strongest and most efficient
army in the world we we stop the russian
army and the russia pay a huge price by
13 000 russian soldiers which were
stay here forever and
with the big numbers of the wounded and
prisoners of poor and with this
situation i think that we should
continue this
effective action from
ukrainian army and for these things we
need two
additional
additional steps
point number one this is the
second front we are not waiting for the
nato troops nato soldiers
but we definitely need
everything from nutrition to ammunition
from anti-aircraft to anti-tank and
the ukrainian army should have something
to fight with the russian soldiers and
it seems to me churchill said that
before the world war ii if you give me
the tools we do your job
this is exactly the same time and that
would be easy understandable mentioning
your great prime minister
and the point number
two this is the situation for the land
raised from the old nato member states
we are ready to pay for that we are
ready to release that but please deliver
for us
not only empty tank and anti-aircraft
but jet fighters especially the old
soviet jet file this mig-29 which you
don't need and with that situation we
return the control we don't need your
pilot but we return the control on the
airspace and that would be the cover for
the nuclear power station that would be
the cover for
civilian object and that would be the
cover for the
ukrainian troops which protect in europe
because you should understand
we
fight not only for our soil
we
fight for the
democracy for the freedom and for the
west and putin is making an aggression
not against ukraine
he make an aggression in every single
nation of the nato of europe and the
history
of the free world is
being forged here in ukraine right now
and with this situation definitely mr
poroshenko but we we were at a funeral
today of four very senior officers
ukrainian officers who were killed in
the attack as you know on the air base
in uh yavariv on sunday uh four very
senior officer how many more people
are are you willing to sacrifice how
many more ukrainian soldiers militia
volunteers you know
will you keep fighting
point number one exactly on this jabari
center for security and peacekeeping
i was
with the
leaders of united states great britain
and
this is the uh
just through in my heart
but this is the question for you
is it
do you understand that ukraine do not uh
give up and ukraine will fight uh
forever until the victory but please we
need that that would be uh
our own job
and
my question how many died justin yavariv
this is 37 people were killed by the
russian missiles attack and this is
happening in less than 20 miles from the
nato border
and it was a symbolic attack because
exactly on this center for peacekeeping
and security which was established for
the
very efficient symbol for the
cooperation between ukraine and nato
which was open
with my presence now uh the it was under
missiles attack of russia and this is
the symbol that putin never stop on
ukraine putin gold further and this type
of funeral of ukrainian hero
ukrainian hero who sacrificed their
lives for
this
for the freedom and for the democracy
and more your support
less victim
very simple arithmetic
and delay with your support means more
victim more blood more lives of
ukrainian civilians and more lives of
ukrainian soldiers and you and we've
understand what does it mean you and
we've understand how we surprise the
world by our unity
from the 24th of february we have now
completely different universe
and we also surprised the world
on day 20 when
yeah mr phinker we're nearly three weeks
in or your country is nearly three weeks
into this war just briefly if you can do
you have a better idea now than you did
at the start what president putin wants
out of this
please
don't trust putin
please
don't be afraid of it
because putin go aspires we together
allow them to go
if it will be strong and united we stop
putin
if you find out your compromise with
putin putting gold further
today he has a compromise
for
demanding ukrainian crimea or ukrainian
donbass
tomorrow he will demand from the great
britain scotland
day after tomorrow
he will demand on the from the united
states alaska
putin
wants to destroy not only ukraine but
the whole west
including uk and us
and
the earlier we stop him
the
more
on the eastern flank of the europe that
would be
much
cheaper price which world will pay for
their peace and security
don't try to to make a compromise with
putin because that would be munich
in the year
1938
that time
hit with the chamberlain
think that they deliver the peace
this is not working and putin in hitler
is very very very similar position but
believe me and remember ukraine is only
the first short and we
need to be united to stop putin now in
ukraine and this is not existence of
ukraine this is not help of ukraine by
the way the
terminal also better that this is not
the conflict this is the wall
[Music]
petro poroshenko i apologize for
interrupting you i do need to bring
people some some breaking news but thank
you very much indeed for joining us
petra poroshenko there former ukrainian
president
well let's bring you an update then uh
from mario paul and officials say now
that 2000 civilian vehicles have left
the besieged port city on an evacuation
route the city council also saying
another 2 000 cars are waiting to leave
along that humanitarian corridor which
runs west for more than 160 miles to the
ukraine-led city of saporisha so that in
a sense for many people is a
breakthrough trying to get some of those
people who are deemed to be starving
short of water 20 days of bombardment
horrendous living conditions and
certainly all of ukraine will celebrate
if they start to try and get some of
those residents out of marijuana well
let's get a broader look then at the
situation on the ground scars
charlotte lomas has more from the sky
new center charlotte
yes hello well it's now day 20 of this
war in ukraine and let's uh now have
more analysis of what's been going on
i'm joined by our defense and security
analyst michael clark uh bring us up to
date then michael what's been happening
today
well charlotte i mean two areas of
interest from a military point of view
uh in kiev and in the south in the push
for odessa
and if we look in kiev uh first talk me
through what's been happening we know
there's been heavy shelling reported
yeah
i mean it seems to me rocket attacks
which because the russians are still a
little bit too far away from the center
of kier
but this encirclement of the city has
taken a lot longer than most of us
thought um they are there in the
northwest and they're there in the
northeast and we see from this the fact
that they've lost hostile airfield the
ukrainians but the fact that they've
been fighting in urping and brovery and
bruca um is very interesting because
that's just about artillery range
for russian howitzers
and what's the howitzer houses are the
attract artillery they look like tanks
but they've got a very big gun on this
152 millimeter gun fires six or eight
rounds a minute
if the russians can get inside these
outer areas of kiev then they can bring
their howitzers in
old-fashioned technology they can
threaten to pummel the whole city rather
than hit them with rockets occasionally
which is what they're doing at the
moment so there'll be a big moment for
the russians if they're only even on
three sides of the city when they can
pummel them with old-fashioned artillery
they're having trouble getting through
to the south
mainly because the ground i mean there's
a lot of marshes there this is the
nipper river lots of forested areas um a
big force a heavy force like the
russians have got here isn't just isn't
moving very quickly and the bridging
equipment doesn't seem to be very good
but if they're on three sides they can
still threaten to pummel kiev with their
howitzers as and when they get them in
place okay then let's take a look a
little bit further south than you
mentioned there to odessa and advance to
odessa describe what's going on um here
oh the issue is mikolayev it's an
important port city it straddles the
delta of the river south bug the
russians again are finding it really
difficult to get over the river they're
not even near it at the moment and as
you can see there
it may be that they've actually got to
go north that they've actually got to
push north to cross the river much
further north in order to come back to
odessa um from the from that side but
even if they get across the river even
at mikolayev they're still 18 80 miles
from odessa going westwards and if they
have to come from in the north they're
more like 120 140 miles so they've got a
long way to go before they can begin to
surround odessa michael clark thank you
so much for that insight uh today three
weeks almost into this war and as you
heard there's still so much going on and
no sign of any let up in this fighting
charlotte thank you well our security
and defense analyst michael clark will
be answering your questions on the
ukraine crisis in a live q and a at 7
p.m and so to enter a question do email
us at news at sky.com or you can find us
on twitter at sky news so that will be
later on
now the justice of secretary dominic
raab has offered britain's help to the
international criminal court to assist
in trying to prosecute russian president
vladimir putin and his regime for war
crimes russia has been accused of
deliberately firing on civilian areas
and using banned weapons to carry out
indiscriminate attacks sky's mark stone
has more
it was a defining image of the war so
far
that moment last wednesday which
captured such cruelty
but if there had been some hope then a
sign that she and her baby would be okay
well it wasn't to be okay
while we were resuscitating her and
treating her for shock we carried out a
cesarean section and took out her
lifeless child more than 30 minutes of
resuscitation didn't produce any results
then more than 30 minutes resuscitation
of the mother didn't produce any results
both died
in the same city over the past 24 hours
well apologies we're going to head
straight to the united nations and
russia's ambassador there vasily
nedenzia
at the very start we said that there are
paragraphs in the resolution which are
not humanitarian and they should not
should not be
in the resolution of the humanitarian
situation yesterday under the
title of breaking news we we learned
that
the french and mexican ambassadors came
came to you and announced that instead
of the security council they will move
this resolution to the general assembly
which
which is not standard practices as you
all know
but they were citing
the inability to adopt this resolution
in the council
because of russia
as i said we we
made it clear that we would be prepared
to adopt a humanitarian resolution
so i think that
that the chances are still there and
that's why we will
put forward our own draft which is
humanitarian and we will put it into the
blue
shortly and we'll see whether the
security council can or cannot fulfill
its mission
to adopt a resolution which will be one
on on the humanitarian situation in
ukraine
with the clear humanitarian provision
like call for negotiated ceasefire
evacuation of civilians the respect of
international human human humanitarian
and human rights law condemnation of
attacks against civilians and civilians
civilian objects safe and unhindered
passage and hindu taxes of humanitarian
assist assistance etc
so i wanted to advance to
to to advise you in advance before we
before we came forward and uh as i said
we'll be shortly
asking you to take questions sir um
thank you sir uh eric sean fox news
ambassador when will vladimir putin stop
his war crimes when will you stop this
obscene
assault against ukraine and will
vladimir putin surrender
and what
well vladimir putin
and what's surrender what
surrender your assault and barbaric war
against ukraine will you stop in the
sake of humanity when when the
goals of the of the special military
operations are achieved it will stop
it was
it was announced from the very beginning
uh i must tell you that i i appreciate
your humane approach but i didn't see
that humane approach
in all these eight years when ukrainian
forces uh ukrainian armed forces and
radicals were shelling and bombing uh
donetsk and lugansk without any reproach
basically any approach from the
international community from the
no comments from the
u.n officials on that on the tissue
yesterday yesterday there was a barbaric
attack of the ukrainian armed forces who
used cluster munitions in which russia
is
is
accused
from
based on sources which which cannot
cannot be identified but they use the
cluster munition in center of the nets
21 persons that person
died
30 plus wounded
no comments i was looking through news
including west media today i didn't come
across a single article
on that on that barbaric attack
yesterday secretary general made
made a stakeout
he didn't say a word on that attack
only one asked the question he said that
if that was deliberate it is condemnable
i must tell you that we are very much
concerned how unofficial including the
top ones
including the secretary junior general
including under secretary general arroz
marie de carlo
assessing the situation the situation in
ukraine uh
accusing russia with discriminant
attacks secretary general yesterday said
that
although that attack is condemnable uh
the most of the of the uh
destruction comes from the russian
sources as if he was he was comparing
two events and and
implying that
implying that
that attack didn't deserve condemnation
pamela falk from cbs news as you know uh
my question is about a ceasefire what
would it take
for russia
to have an overall not just humanitarian
ceasefire what does ukraine need to do
and what's in your resolution what what
are you proposing on humanitarian
carters thank you i i decided i cited a
few uh things obvious for the
humanitarian resolution you will see it
soon shortly because it will be it will
be published
for an overall season negotiated
of course it should be negotiated and
this ceasefire will uh will take place
when uh when uh conditions that were put
forward
by russia will be implemented and they
are they're very well
known you just lay out what those
conditions are
demilitarization of ukraine
densification of ukraine
no threat which would come from the
territory from that country
to russia
no
no
joining nato president zilensky
announced
just a few hours perhaps ago that he
understands that
that the ukraine will not join not
citing uh in particular his
disappointment with the way that nato
reacted but uh that but the goal of
ukraine joining nato is in the ukrainian
constitution so it should be it should
be dropped from there uh first and
foremost i think that i think that's
enough question ambassador are the the
parallels yes sir between the u.s
invasion of iraq in 2003 you've been
very critical russia has been very
critical you've also been very critical
of the 2011 invasion attack on libya led
by nato
are there parallels between what the us
did in 2003 and the unilateral actions
we are seeing from from russia and the
criticism that is being leveled against
u.n officials that are simply seeking to
defend the u.n charter
every situation is unique but i do not
recall the level of
uh
outrage hysterics uh that
that
that
that u.s
invasion of iraq
no no resolutions nothing if you
remember no resolution of the security
council
uh not nothing that would be comparable
to what what we're experiencing today
thank you very much
again i really can't hear you with your
mask on
yes
well there then
there then is the uh russian ambassador
to the united nations asked at the start
of that will you stop this war for the
sake of humanity
and uh once again saying we will stop
when the demilitarization has happened
pointing out as he put it that uh the
area of donbass had been shelled by
ukraine for eight long years with no
reproach uh from western leaders then so
the words there of vasili nevensia the
russian ambassador to the u.n
she's bringing some breaking news now
we're talking about happy anniversary in
corridors concerning mariopol earlier
the red cross says that 70 bosses are
ready now in sumi in the northeast to
evacuate civilians assembling for an
operation that it hopes to start today
so we'll certainly monitor that for you
so after those uh 2000 vehicles from
mariopol and now sue me so fingers
crossed for them
now chelsea football club has announced
that it will not be able to sell tickets
for saturday's saturday's fa cup top
middlesbrough as a result the club is
asking the fa for the game to be played
behind closed doors part of the fallout
of course from sanctions on the chelsea
roman abramovich he's among seven
russian billionaires added to a british
sanctions list last week today the
government announcing sanctions against
a further 370 russian and belarusian
individuals and entities mr abramovich
thought to have traveled to moscow in
the last 24 hours and uh tracking him is
our correspondent jason farrell
yeah well he was
photographed in tel aviv airport um uh
where he'd visited uh israel sunday
night and he was photographed on monday
got a flight here to istanbul
but didn't stay for very long left in
the early hours
this morning
and it's not clear exactly why he made
that trip to israel or indeed here to
istanbul
there's speculation that uh a museum
bayrack businessman here in turkey
had expressed an interest in buying
chelsea
and he claims to have met abramovic
last week and has set up another uh
meeting with him uh later in this week
however of course chelsea is no longer
abramovitz to sell it doesn't mean he
couldn't get involved in the sale but he
cannot benefit from the sale that's what
the government has said uh that that
would be the terms of their
license to chelsea if they wanted to
sell it it had to be clear that
abramovich could not benefit from the
sale because he is sanctioned
not only abramovic coming here but his
super yacht solaris uh which had been
in actually been in barcelona four days
ago
seems to be now heading down here he's
got two super yachts one also off the
coast of north africa have to say if it
had remained in barcelona it might well
have been seized by the eu because he's
also been added today to the eu
sanction list we now know that abramovic
is back in moscow having left here in
the early hours so
his ability to travel spend money is
being tightened as these sanctions
tighten on him
jason thank you very much indeed so day
20 then of russia's invasion
humanitarian corridors we talked about
we'll keep you posted on that throughout
the afternoon but here trying to keep a
sense of normality for the young
children of lev despite the funeral
service attended by so many this morning
but here as you can see the children of
levy of being entertained they're trying
to keep
at least in western parts of ukraine
these children protected from the war
more of course throughout the afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
you